all right my friends let's look at some
stunning polling numbers Donald Trump's
favorite pollster Rasmussen is a
right-wing friendly pollster has a new
poll out where Donald Trump is down by
12 points to Joseph R Biden Jr when
other polls don't look good for Trump
Trump often says look at Rasmussen
Rasmussen does good polling well here is
Rasmussen latest poll with RMG research
saying Trump is down 12 to Biden 48 to
36 with 9% not sure and 6% supporting
some other candidate now important to
understand that there are 15% here that
are either for some third party
candidate or aren't sure yet
if they mostly consolidate around Trump
in November that can get Trump close
enough where even he could lose the
popular vote by a few points but still
win the electoral college we saw that in
2016 but the reason that this poll
matters is that last week when CNN said
hey we have a poll done with SSRS
reliable reputable pollster says Trump
is down 14 Trump said it was fake had
his lawyers send a cease and desist
letter to CNN demanded an apology and
demanded a retraction
we now have a traditionally right-wing
pollster saying well it's not a 14-point
lead for Biden but it's a 12-point lead
for Biden and in addition we have an
abacus data or data poll from yesterday
which also has this as a 14-point lead
for Joe Biden so what is our take away
the take away is nothing every single
one of you of us me you have everybody
every one of us has to vote no matter
what any poll says because Donald Trump
is desperate and he will do anything he
can to get reelected they are going to
try to suppress the vote they are going
to try to come up with some October
Surprise we talked earlier in the show
about maybe some emergency use vaccine
we can assume nothing if in your state
Biden is polling ahead by 30 points what
do you do you go and vote because we
can't take a chance now let's look at
some stunning state polls in the
meantime an admittedly left-leaning PP
people has Biden plus 14 in New Mexico
an epic MRA poll has Biden plus 16 in
Michigan now remember none of this
changes anything about what we have to
do but understand how 2016 went and then
if you look at 2016 where Donald Trump
won Michigan by 0.2 percent 0.2 percent
if Trump goes from winning Michigan by
0.2 percent to losing it by 16 or even
12 or even 8 or even 5 that signals a
massive change from the 2016 election
because it probably means a bunch of
states aren't going to go Donald Trump's
way another important state to look at
is Iowa Donald Trump won Iowa by 10 in
2016 the latest poll from the Des Moines
Register good pollster has Trump up only
one Trump won by 10 in Iowa in 2016
currently Trump is winning by one in
Iowa we have 50 individual elections
when we do a presidential election it is
a national choice
but they are 50 individual elections
they're correlated though if Trump's
margin of victory in Iowa goes from 10
to 1 it's a signal about other states
but again third time I'm saying this and
you're gonna hear this from me a lot our
mission our assignment individually is
we vote no matter what state were in we
vote no matter what the polls say if in
mid-october the stock market spikes and
Trump claims he got us a vaccine it
could push him to victory and then we
have four more years of Trump Trump
selecting Supreme Court justices Trump
putting in more federal and appeals
court judges so we need to be prepared
for something in October we need to be
ready to deal with it meaning every
single person must plan to vote now I
want to focus in a little more
specifically on Arkansas if you are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into a
doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way to take control of your
health and get personalized care from
the comfort of your home it's a service
called steady MD they're one of our
sponsors you take a quiz you get matched
with a licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor you establish a meaningful
relationship with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call each doctor at
steady MD has a limited number of
patients so they actually have time to
listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve they can do
almost everything an in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns send
prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy and anything they can't do
online they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example you don't need
insurance it's only 99 bucks a month
with no other fees or co-pays there are
so many practical advantages to using
steady MD for primary care and it's also
so much more affordable go to steady MD
comm slash Pakman to take the free quiz
see which doctor is right for you I took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs in situation the doctor they gave
me is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started just click the
link right underneath this video